between Lauren and my mom I am and all
that estrogenic energy I'm the only guy
part of what makes you who you are
you're a real man but you get it you
have a softer side I gotta tell you you
know I as men you know you're like oh
yeah we're gonna raise my son and and
but having all daughters it's the
greatest blessing I've ever had
you may ask yourself what does Dwayne
the rock Johnson and his charismatic
personality have to do with a video
about one piece after all you can't
really say that these two topics are too
closely related right but what if I told
you that the rock and one piece do have
something in common or rather that there
is a character in a story of one piece
that closely resembles Johnson in more
than just one way Frankie is without a
doubt one of the more flashy characters
in the story
at first glance comparing him to the
rock may seem a little bit superficial
but I promise you that it will all make
sense once we make it to the end of this
video so bear with me here to be
completely honest with you I personally
didn't really like Frankie as a
character too much for quite some time
and I can't really tell you why maybe it
was his unusual character design or his
rowdy like language that didn't really
speak to me but I simply couldn't enjoy
him as a character as much as I did the
other straw hats at that time and then
as I grew older and got more and more
involved with one piece I noticed
something weird I caught myself liking
the chapters and scenes with Frankie
more and more and before I knew it I
thought that he was actually an amazing
character how the hell did that happen
as I came to realize my mistake was that
I thought that Frankie was designed to
appeal to younger readers and in a
certain way that is probably true but
the way his character is designed
actually resonates a lot more with my
older self so let's find out who Frankie
the cyborg truly is
and why Oda might have written the rock
into one piece by accident Frankie is a
powerfully-built tall man with a height
of at least seven feet or a little over
two meters in case you're like me and
don't know how much that really is an
immediate eye catcher our Frankie's
forearms which are enormous ly big while
his biceps are comparatively small the
same goes for his muscular upper body
with unproportional e thin legs
he has brightly colored blue hair and
blue star tattoos on his forearms and
going with his existence as a cyborg he
has a very geometric looking face with a
metallic nose and triangular chin his
choice of clothing usually comprises of
speedos and an open Hawaiian Aloha shirt
with a large golden chain necklace
around his neck before becoming a cyborg
Frankie went half-naked simply because
he felt like it now however his cyborg
body is built in a way that covering
himself up would actually limit him in
using his technical features that
include a variety of weapons and other
let's say interesting features also he
only wears a shirt to cover his back the
only part of his body he cannot reach
and modify and as a result is most
vulnerable to damage to make his
character even more quirky and round
things up his body runs entirely on Cola
Frankie grew up on water 7 as an orphan
boy from the South Bloo where he was
thrown overboard by his parents who also
were pirates when he was barely four
years old he was found by the legendary
shipwright Tom who took him in and made
him his apprentice Frankie's real name
is actually Cudi flam but his fellow
apprentice ice berg decided to nickname
him Frankie and the name stuck ever
since when Tom was arrested for building
the RO Jackson for the Pirate King Goll
D Roger he managed to evade his sentence
by offering to build a sea train in
order to help the struggling city
together with ice berg and Frankie he
managed to finish the train in
however span 'dom an official of the
world government frame Tom for attacking
water 7 using Frankie's own personal
fleet of mini battleships that he had
built to fight of the Sea Kings his goal
was to get his hands on the blueprints
of the ancient weapon pluton that was in
Tom's possession when Tom was taken to
an Islamic Frankie tried to stand in its
path and was tragically run over heavily
injured he drifted to a ship where he
modified his own body into a cyborg and
returned to water 7 several years later
there he revealed himself to iceberg who
was now the mayor of the prospering
water 7 from him
Frankie received the plans for the
pluton and he decided to protect iceberg
and water 7 from the shadows to do so he
became a ship dismantler a bounty hunter
and a thug and he also formed the
Frankie family taking cast outs from all
over the city so now that we know
Frankie's crazy and tragic backstory
let's look at his character Frankie has
been filled with positive
characteristics by Oda that maybe aren't
so apparent at first glance but let's
start with a more obvious one Frankie
has shown us over and over again how
strong-willed he is and he takes it to
the utmost extreme by performing self
surgery and modification on himself
while he was at the verge of death after
being run over by the C train now I
would say that this is a feat that maybe
even a Luffy or a Zorro would have had
difficulties with regardless of the
technical knowledge that has to be
involved here hand in hand with this
goes his craftiness his sharp wit and
his creativity that make him such a
unique shipwrights Frankie is one of the
very few people in the world that are
able to create and handle a technology
on an advanced level not only is his own
cyber technology incredibly advanced but
he also had no problem understanding and
integrating dr. vegher Punk's invention
during the time skip Frankie also has a
very free-spirited and eccentric
personality
he's proud to be who he is with all of
his quirks and unique features and he
also doesn't like to follow social norms
let alone the laws of the world
governments this also reflects really
well in his language that is kind of
punky and includes him rolling his arm
say Mysterio O'Mara no no no not I could
like getting out get that another side
of Frankie that often gets overlooked is
his altruism and kindness towards others
whether it's with the children on punk
hazard or the tanto de Andres Rosa our
cyborgs clearly cares not only for his
crew and family but also those around
him in general this is closely related
to his emotional sight that makes him
tear up very quickly when hearing a
tragic story most importantly though and
I think this is one of the core messages
of this video Frankie is actually
incredibly mature despite all of his
goofiness when stopping the C train he
shouts that he wants to be like his
father figure Tom someone who took him
in even after his parents abandoned him
so that's what he did he went through
the streets of water seven and took in
those people who had been forgotten by
everyone else
he gave them a family and a place to
belong we can also see this in Frankie's
relationship with everyone in the crew
there he takes on the role of a kind of
father or a big brother for especially
the younger ones teaching us off about
engineering taking care of chopper and
supporting those who need him like Luffy
Andres Rosa and Robin in Anna's Lobby
while we often see him goofing around
and entertaining the true he always
seems to keep serious matters in mind
and his worldview in general is one of
the most mature in the crew as well I
think that this maturity was something
that I didn't manage to see when I was
younger and it also explains why I came
to love Frankie as a character a little
later than some of the other straw hats
it seems to go against his character and
yet when you look at the big picture it
fits perfectly
interestingly enough this maturity also
reflects in Frankie's drivers for
character development
because in a way he truly is already
matured his only inner need is his
inability to forgive himself for the
death of his master Tom otherwise
Frankie doesn't really have anything he
has to change in order to become a
better person yes he indeed did do some
immoral things like beating up a sob or
stealing from pirates like the straw
hats but he mostly did all of this out
of a sense of atonement and love in
memory of Tom he decided to spend the
rest of his days on water 7 attacking
incoming thieves and looters organizing
all the thoughts so that he could keep
the city's crime in check and overall
protecting the city that Tom loved so
much Frankie's dream on the other hand
is really hands-on he wanted to create a
dream ship out of Adam Wood and see its
sail around the world
in other words Franky is literally
living his dream with the straw hats at
the moment at the same time he also
strives to become stronger to be able to
protect his friends on their dangerous
journey no wonder then that Frankie
values family and kindness just as much
as he values freedom and of course
craftsmanship so how then does this
impressive cyborg of a man influence the
story being the shipwrights of the straw
hats
Frankie is the one in abling the crew to
sail on the dangerous waters of the
Grand Line in the first place he was the
one who built a sunny and also is the
one to repair her and keep her in good
shape over the course of their journey
in other words Frankie
quite literally is responsible for
moving the plot along apart from his
duties as a craftsman though he also is
an important fighting asset when things
get a little bit heated and more often
than not he actually plays a major role
in events taking place on Anna's Lobby
he helped the straw hat save Robin as a
matter of fact he was the one to unchain
and protect her until the rest of the
crew arrived and then later he helped
everyone escape by using a cadaver
blowing the blockade of buster call
ships apart and sending the going Mary
flying through the air
another detail that is often forgotten
is that Frankie most likely still holds
the knowledge of how to rebuild the
ancient weapon pluton a plot point that
might well become relevant again down
the line and finally in terms of
character development he also provides
guidance for the younger crew members
helping them feel safe and comfortable
on this dangerous journey in that
context it's of course also worth
looking at Frankie's own character arc
since Frankie has a very mature and as a
result nearly complete character his
development over the course of the story
is rather minor and altruistic Frankie
definitely still is working on
overcoming his guilt regarding Tom's
death but it is nothing that Oda puts
too much into focus for us still we can
see Frankie making progress in that
regards be defeating spanda who was
responsible for his pain
joining the straw hats meeting Tom's
brother Dan on Fishman Island or simply
fulfilling his dream sailing with his
friends it is a very low-key but
nonetheless fulfilling change of
character that I hope will be brought up
again at one point in the story for his
character as a whole I feel like there
are three arcs in particular when
Frankie was at the center of events the
first one is obviously the water seven
and an Islamic arc and yes that is also
Robins big arc no doubt about it but
that Oda managed to make it the major
point of events for not just one but two
straw hats just confirms for me how
great this art truly was starting out as
antagonists Luffy and Frankie came to
forgive and trust each other over the
course of events and after all they went
through together in the end there really
was no other option for either of them
to not journey together from then on out
the Timescape was another confirmation
about how important Frankie would be for
the crew stranded on the island of curry
curry the hometown of the infamous dr.
vegher Punk he was able to further
improve himself as well as the son
all that for the sake of protecting his
friends and making the sunny into a ship
of Dreams for the crew finally in
Frankie got to play a major role in the
events unfolding on dressrosa
where not only he showed true bravery
and kindness in protecting the tone Tata
Luffy but also had an ideologically
amazing fight against sand your pink of
the donki hote family frankie may not
seem like it at first glance but he
truly is a fantastic character that is
much more complex and contributes much
more to the plot than anyone would think
so why the rock I hope by now you
already have a feeling what I'm talking
about here because Frankie and Dwayne
Johnson actually share a lot of
similarities and in more than just one
way let's start with some of the more
obvious ones I personally think that
both Frankie and the rock are extremely
likable characters they both have a very
positive aura around them and basically
whose energy and motivation then of
course there is the look I mean come on
if these guys don't look similar I don't
know beside the thing with the glasses
which I found super hilarious once I
realized it by the way they both have
the bulky muscular strongmen look they
also both have a connection to Hawaii
and Oda
actually stated that Frankie would be
American if one piece took place in the
real worlds I mean those are minor
things but I just feel like they around
all the analogy really well then of
course we have their upbringing both had
a difficult childhood but they also
managed to work their way out of there
through the enthusiasm and positivity
and finally managed to lead a life that
brings them happiness every day finally
I feel like they also resemble each
other immensely in their personality
both strongly value kindness and humor
and both are extremely eccentric and
free spirits it's now that I think about
it in a way they even resemble each
other in the way they changed over the
years pre times get frankly with his
rowdy like appearance really reminds me
of a younger wrestling rock while post
time skip Frankie
is closer to the Dwayne Johnson today
mature altruistic and somehow looking
more like a tank than before so there
you have it with Frankie Oda has created
a truly amazing character and by
accident might have made the rock join
the straw hats
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching making this video turn out to
be a lot more fun than I expected I
really enjoy making all of these videos
but for Frankie I just kept coming
across these small details that I just
found so fascinating also I will be
answering some of your questions in the
comments below so don't forget to leave
a comment and maybe even a like today I
also want to give a shout out to my
wonderful translators a big thank you to
Hana and Rodrigo Reba who translated my
last video into German and Spanish
you're a huge help in growing this
community and making this content
accessible to more people if you should
also be interested in creating captions
for this or any other video on this
channel you can either contact me on
Twitter or simply start right away
YouTube will let you translate
everything line by line very straight
forward also a big thank you to all my
patreon supporters who enable me to
create content for you on a regular
basis if you also want to support this
channel you can find a link to my page
in the comments below
finally if you want to hear more from me
also make sure to follow me on Twitter
if you like this video don't forget to
like share and subscribe to be notified
for any future content of mine or
dislike don't share and unsubscribe it's
a free world people I hope to see around
next time and until then have a great
week oh yeah and don't forget to turn
your notifications on because YouTube
can sometimes be forgetful bye
you
[Music]